こんにちははじめ社長です皆さんみーっ
ば今日は今日は何の日かすみません何気ない何気ない普通の8月だと思いなところなん
ですけども今日はなんかあの結果号ちゃいだ
カメオして月茶業界に今日は各信頼革命が起きる日になりました
なんとまあネット見てる人は皆さん知ってると思うんですけどもう何ももしガチャと
いうものがありましてあのそうぞ
を曲げないなぜ方の話をされていただきますの傘がちゃった2回しだ
あの
申し遅れました私でガチャがザ大好きでございますよろしくお願い致しますガチャが
立ってカップしてる
を開けるとなんかにフィギュアとか物とかこういろんなものが入ってるんですよそれが
まあ
4坂里言われるものでございますぞ根本を覆す
ダンボードしガザというものが本日から特定の店舗で発売されるようになりました
がホームページとがめっちゃられたんで僕きっと調べてたんですけど
結論から言いますとあの田舎には売られていません
なのでももちろん僕が今住んでる静岡にも取り扱い店舗んなし買いに行くとしたら東京
か愛知に行かなきゃいけないっていう状態だったんですけどなんとなんとですね
運の良いことに興じたううーむのな姉じゃあさんが静岡に
ブーブー
20週3便でした
でしたうさいぞとして正よしまさ
あっはぁこれでこれでおらずど5寸グッズを手に入れるぞれ
と思ったんですけど驚きの結果にまぁちょっと嫌な予感はしてたんです安の女王
麺茶紅茶売り切れていますまず書店ではキャバレーなお店に行ってもらったんですけど
もこちら
談合脊振系来年のためにもう一箇所行きましたがそちらも談合し sold out
じゃあさらに上のもう1店舗託されているところに行ってもらったんですけどそちらも
談合して完売しました
やべぇやべぇ完全に出遅れたそうなんです暖房ましてガチャ今どこにも売っていません
それでも欲しい
それでも欲しいと思ってしまった僕はメルカリをこう調べてみるととんでもない価格で
取引されていてすごい家なきボツになりました
ところが僕のマネージャーさんは取り扱い店舗に乗っていないヨドバシカメラで
たまたま行ったところその
よと橋カメラに
ん
単語も4月が売ってましたーーーはい
うんみたい中動画ではまず手に入らない
東京でもなぁなんて思ってに入れないでしょレアな伝説の山後7月はこちらにあります
こちらです
泣く子
これらしいですよすごくねあのガチャ月あって買ってる中に入ってるんですけどももう
これ自体がカプセルになってるみたいですそしてお値段なんと衝撃
1回
500円ですめっちゃリアルみたいな前営業マンすごい良くてめっちゃ欲しいと思っ
てるだけの情報でた時なんかやっぱ案の定バカ売れしていった本当に手に入りやすい
です
そうあみ子何もやって
光沢がすごいこの垣間見える中のこの感じがすごいリアル
ちょっとだってすごいな本当に永作開けてみましたはオープン
ああああああ
r 2
俺待ってこれちょっと貼ってく
待って待ってん
えーっ日々済むとあっへっ
めいちゃん固定階ですけどすーげーであるですなんかいいえ
アンプだかちょーでしたゲイであるですね
談合の神の構造を徹底研究し
まるまる体を再現した衝撃のスケールモデルええとまずは足はでも外側に開いたって
書いてあります開いてみましょう
うぇい
はい全部避難方が出来ましたああいうというふうに関してしました
2の談合の人にはるかに大きいですけどもう
じゃあこれじゃないんだ急に行ったら本当に怖いなぁで1体だけだとムル足りない
年間を任期付きで個性請求とかのみたいなのでその水に帰る可能な限りの数買ってきて
くださいって言ったところ
家畜を変えましたが
ゆっくり国は普通のあの団子所ゆらさんですけどどっちが点がある日のですね白くなっ
ちゃった飼い主様にいたんだような白いやつフェスに侵食されて青くなっちゃった
なんか無視思います合計3色になってますね
いやハン力手に入れたのでか言ってよこれちょっと全部開封してみましょう
goo ん
[音楽]
ん
何か
売れる言うがまさに気がします
よくないですか健康を保ってるリアルなんですかどっか置いとけば誰かベベルんじゃ
ないかなということで適当に動画において見えちゃうと思いますではいかん
があるん
[音楽]
すまんだ尾崎が下がったよっ
確かにいい
ん
[音楽]
多分まずほどだーっぐらいだからいぶりっ
me
ううっうぅうう
ええええええ
re うっ